you were like I will be the best actor
that you've ever seen I will knock this
thing out of the park I'm going to do
all these things in order but if I'm
honest I see a guy who's just trying to
get tasks done which is often a distance
it's a way to distance yourself from
yourself what do you think about
Eric I I don't even know how to answer
that question and and that's why I'm I
don't even I just I don't have a and I
don't know what that disconnect is I'm
just being you I don't know I don't I
don't
know there was a moment
when you talked about I don't have
anybody and then the next sentence was
but my life's great and I'm going and it
was just this quick little drive by of a
window where we saw a really lonely guy
how'd that happen